[Applaudissements]
après vous avoir félicité Monsieur le
Premier Ministre pour votre nomination
je voudrais évoquer les propos de votre
ministre des Affaires étrangères à Kiev
déclarant que l'aide à l'Ukraine restera
une priorité il faut maintenant tenir
cette promesse la situation est devenue
critique les crimes de guerre du boucher
du kremelin infligent chaque jour un
atroce supplice à la population civile
d'Ukraine les Ukrainiens qui ont
brillamment contre-attaqué à carkiv et
Kerson en 2022 son sont aujourd'hui en
position de faiblesse parce que depuis
le début le soutien des démocraties peut
se résumer par la formule trop peu trop
tard si nous avions livré à temps les
chars les missiles les batteries
anti-aériennes l'armée russe n'aurait pu
reconstituer ses défenses et faire
échouer la contreoffensive de 2023 nous
sommes en train de renouveler cette
erreur depuis des mois Zelenski attend
les 60 milliards de dollars de
Washington bloqué par les trumpistes au
Congrès et les 50 milliards d'euros de
l'Europe paralys par ses 5è colonnes
Orban le collabo en Hongrie Le Pen et
mélenchant les chiens chiens à leur
Poutine en France et tant d'autres
ailleurs nos tergiversations mettent
l'Ukraine en grand danger je pèse mes
mots une défaite serait celle de
l'Europe tout entière un formidable
stimulant pour la Chine face à Taïwan
pour le Docteur Folamour de Corée du
Nord pour les Moras iraniens tueurs de
femmes au Moyen-Orient il serait
impensable que le prochain Conseil
européen du 1er février ne déjoue pas
les manœuvres d'Orban le corrompu et ne
débloque pas la totalité de l'aide
promise à l'Ukraine je vous demande
aujourd'hui l'engagement formel d'y
parvenir et de soutenir sans restriction
le fond d'investissement européen en
défense de 100 milliards proposé par le
commissaire français Thierry Breton en
ce début de mandat vous vous dites sans
doute monsieur le Premier ministre que
vous serez jugé sur vos résultats dans
notre pays et c'est exact mais à
l'échelle de l'histoire votre
gouvernement et tous les gouvernements
de l'Europe seront jugés à l'ône de la
victoire ou de la défaite des démocrates
en Ukraine face à l'international
reconstitué des
[Applaudissements]
dictateurs